it is time now because in celebration of
my new book that will be out on May 14th
which is what Tuesday
you're gonna reveal my favorite
interview of all time you loved all the
interviews right yeah I want to make
that clear yeah how should I do this
Robin should I just announce that the
person is on mic right now and I
announce him or should I tell you why or
how do you want to do this I think I
want to know why okay I went home after
the interview and I said this is the
first time in my life I feel like I
asked every question I needed to ask I
feel like I had one of the most sincere
conversations and it was so fulfilling
it was funny it was brilliant in terms
of what the guest was saying there were
moments that I picked up on things in
this and then we talked about a variety
of topics
you felt completely complete was a
complete conversation you couldn't have
done it any better this guest has a TV
show I'll tell you that right now
this guest and his TV show he can't
reveal I feel all sides of him and I
don't think people even understand how
super funny he is and how insightful and
how bright and we got to know that and I
even thought in my own delusion I
thought afterwards oh my god this guest
and I we're gonna become like really
good friends he's like my brother
he's like my brother like he's the
brother I'd would want and that person
is mr. Conan O'Brien
Conan are you there yes I'm here Howard
you know Conan I always thought that
because I just want to stay on this a
little bit about picking you as the
favorite interview of all time it was
very awesome miss I think it's a mistake
no I swear to be really honest with you
I think Paul McCartney Billy Joel I
think I think you're gonna regret this
don't you admit that sometimes you have
a guest you vibe with that person and
you think maybe you don't experience
this but but you think oh my goodness we
just had this incredible connection and
we'll probably end up calling one
another but there's really no facility
for that like when you're left yes yes
yeah I thought I know what you're
talking about
I should call Conan and somehow have a
relationship with him but you don't you
never do that right you know I don't but
I know
exactly what you're talking about for
example when you and I had that
interview I left and this is like two
people that you know it's like we had
sex
Brian we and and in a lot of ways I
think we did and that day I agree and we
stumbled we stumbled away from each
other and what happened was I felt wow I
think that was really good I really
liked that interview that was I really
felt like I connected with Howard and
then I was in New York and I was walking
around and people were coming up to me
on the street and telling me how much
that meant to them and I thought what
are you talking about I mean we just I
just you know I killed an hour with
Howard we had a good time it felt good
but I never stopped hearing about that
interview and that's why I've been loath
to talk to you since because I thought
we're never gonna we're never gonna
match that so I should just get out of
the business well that's always what
I've been worried been trying to do